und es kommt das war ein euro ticket
aber die kommen und wie funktioniert das
noch mal ab juni könnt ihr bis august
für neun euro im monat mit bus und bahn
fahren das angebot gilt für den gesamten
nahverkehr und auch videos in der
zweiten klasse gte c sind aber zum
beispiel ausgeschlossen das ticket
bekommt ihr ganz einfach am
fahrkartenautomaten oder am
ticketschalter opel geht in die apps der
verkehrsanbieter ankauft es dort so das
ticket sogar eine extra apple gemeinsam
von den verkehrsunternehmen geplant
wurde bei der deutschen bahn startet der
verkauf zum beispiel am 23 und falls ihr
euch jetzt fragt was passiert wenn wir
schon abo ab zum beispiel im
semesterticket dass deutlich mehr als
nur ein auto kostet den fall soll die
differenz erstattet werden und wenn ihr
dann so entwickelt habt könnt ihr damit
in ganz deutschland plant zum beispiel
sogar bis nach sylt so als idee für den
nächsten kurzurlaub habt ihr euch so ein
ticket zu kaufen
wenn ja wohin jetzt für euch für die
kommentare